are you familiar with these parts of the
frontier not with this part not yet
[Music]
there is an episode of hysteria about
the barbarians I have orders to obey
[Music]
I'm speaking of particular situations
situations where I am probing for the
truth since all is not well here I
expect further measures will be taken
jobs are conducting operations to
correct the situation that you've
allowed to develop what they do to you
you want me to take you back to your
family the barbarians whom you are
chasing this is their land they know
every inch of it you do not did you
really say that there will be a great
war against the Empire pain is truth
that is how you get it you have no idea
how tiresome your behavior is
you are an obscene torture we have set
procedures ready to go
intrusion asleep consorting with the
enemy
get out I want these people out of here
[Music]
we will end these troubles
[Applause]
we will put down the enemy
and that will be the end of it
[Applause]
you